so I told you that Rodrigo Duterte many
times we talked about the Filipino
president Rodrigo Duterte who pushes for
the killing of suspected drug dealers
and drug users in the Philippines an
absolute and total authoritarian
dictatorial type has advocated shooting
women in the vagina he's admitted to
murdering people in cold blood when he
was mayor of I believe it was the vow a
city in the Philippines just generally a
really bad guy and Donald Trump is said
before that he thinks the ter Tay is
just doing a hell of a job with the drug
war in the Philippines which of course
includes the sort of authorization for
guerrilla style killing in the streets
of people suspected to use or deal drugs
Trump often is simpatico with
authoritarian leaders not so much in
line though with the leaders of Western
democracies it seems like the leaders of
Western democracies are sort of
disgusted by Donald Trump in many ways
but Trump and some of these other
authoritarian type dictatorial of
leaders Trump seems to have a lot in
common with we have now learned through
an Axios exclusive report that Donald
Trump is privately talking about how he
would love to copy the idea of the death
penalty for drug dealers and drug
traffickers a source that has spoken to
Trump specifically about this topic says
that Trump says a lot that he likes the
idea of more usage of the death penalty
specifically for drug dealers and Trump
will reportedly often joke by saying you
know the Chinese and Filipinos don't
have a problem they just kill them but
it's not just jokes because five sources
who have spoken to Trump about this
particular issue say this is actually
Trump something Trump gets passionate
about saying that drug dealers are as
bad as serial killers and that they
should all get the death penalty and
Trump has said he would love a new law
to execute drug dealers in America but
he actually seems not to be so deluded
that he thinks it could pass in the
United States of America
these are the attitudes of third-world
dictators and this is the mindset that
has most in common with Donald Trump's
ideology we've talked many times we
don't really know what Trump's true
political ideology is a lot of it seems
to be based just around getting people
to say he's doing a good job or exerting
power or whatever else the case may be
from all the reports we've seen Trump
really is passionate about wanting to
execute drug dealers and I have to
mention that this is also not small
government conservatism right this is
ridiculous and insanely disturbing but
it's only slightly shocking right
because I'm so desensitized by the
absurdity that has been normalized under
Donald Trump that it's nuts for an
American president
to seem so passionate about executing
drug dealers what we should be doing is
ending the war on drugs altogether and
decriminalizing a lot of what's going on
around drugs I'm only like a little bit
taken aback by it because it's Trump you
know yeah and you know I'm I'm against
the death penalty in all cases but at
least when it comes to murder there's
this idea that the the punishment can
fit the crime sure you can't say the
same thing about drug trafficking and
drug dealing here's what they would say
Shinto all of our problems with what
they would say is that the trafficking
leads to many many deaths through
overdose through the violence
surrounding the drug trade which is not
wrong but the solution isn't the death
penalty the solution is decriminalized
ideally legalized use the tax money to
treat this as a as a health issue is a
public health issue but at that time
then you can make the same case about
drunk driving and criminal negligence
and a whole bunch of other crimes no
question about it
I wonder if Trump realizes that like at
least some of the money he's probably
been laundering through his businesses
is drug money right like Trump Trump's
not innocent when it comes to the entire
drug world and the bigger picture is
Trump wants drug reform that includes
harsher sentences including Matt harsher
mandatory minimums for drug dealing and
we need to oppose that but at a higher
level what will we do with the
manufacturers of major opiate
painkillers right I mean they're
increasingly being
dude if we apply Trump's logic shouldn't
there be death penalty punishments also
for the manufacturers of some of these
opiate painkillers that are leading to
so many overdose deaths I don't know but
the point is that if drugs kill and we
need to kill enablers who's a bigger
enabler than the opiate painkiller
manufacturers that are pushing doctors
to prescribe more and the real policy
direction happens to be the opposite of
what Trump wants it's the opposite of
what Jeff Sessions wants its legalizing
drugs decimating the black market yes
the black market still exists when you
legalize but it is much much smaller you
reduce the demand for the street dealers
you reduce the impetus for the
international trafficking and it is a
very very good thing discuss this with
us on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t today's program is
made possible in part by fruit or which
is a social forecasting game for your
phone where players come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events you go on the app find a
future event you feel confident enough
about to make a prediction and make a
bet on the outcome that you think will
happen using the apps in-game fake
currency
if your prediction is right you're
rewarded with more points you can
compete with others who are making their
own prediction to see who is the best
forecaster there's no real world money
or cryptocurrency involved the fun of
futur is interacting with others and
showing the world your skills at
predicting the future will Democrats
take the White House house this year
will Trump run for re-election will
Trump ever build the wall you can go
ahead and make your predictions show off
your forecasting skills and there are
also monthly competitions and prizes for
top forecasters and I'm on foote or you
can wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and make forecast it's
free it's on Android and iOS as well as
on web browsers and it's spelled fut you
you are calm